hi everyone
first of all i am actually the native
russian speaker so don't judge my heart
i'm in armenia for two months so i'm
already working noon at noon
so all the results that we will discuss
today
it's the result for two months of work
so
the agenda for today
is here yeah the first question is uh
the first point is where you will decide
to speed up language model and the
second is how we do that
this one is our experience
in two months that we have and our
future plans and a little demo that
everyone can
do better
so
so yes and motivation is so
every computer vision engineer and
solution
are trying to accelerate their inference
so the usage of neural net
uh
so
why i hope you guys don't do that
nobody knows uh when i was born in
spurbank we actually got the bunch size
of one for
maybe two and that's it nobody was
interested to
accelerate the inference but that's
actually significant for encoder part of
transformers for natural language
understanding
so yeah
uh at um we are trying to do the
universal search in your search what
does it mean
we are trying to make any data domain
like text like image like uh audio video
maybe uh html file or something like
that we are trying to make the search
and take all the data mine is the query
and as the response
so
yeah we need fast inference and we want
to rebuild uh the index of this search
engine uh in flight so whenever we get
the
uh
the data the new data from the user in
their data
for our database we need to reconstruct
the
search engine the index
so yeah you need to do that fast
actually the the fast
importers like this or something like
that
this also needs the
recommendation system and questionnaire
systems so yeah this is how the
universal search engine looks like
you can
write the textual query and get the
images as a result
so yeah
how we make
the encoders faster
the first one
the first approach is quantization
the second one is the specification
print the distillation and optimized ml
compilers
we will focus today with the
cursory but i think
more about the quantization today talks
so
yeah what is the quantization uh it's
easy to think about that like you just
round the number
with you have the logical number and you
just run in it so yeah you will
have less bits to use and this uh that
produce the less computation and less
memory usage
so yeah this is that so it's actually
easy and safe
to for
for
or before 16 but it's a bit tricky with
the intake and so on support because you
can significantly lose the accuracy
so yeah there's lots of types of
quantization we'll discuss three of them
with the name quantization uh that's the
quantization where you
try to
change
your
weights in neural net
inside the inference group so when you
improve the model when you use that when
you try to get the imbalance uh you are
you change the weight so but that works
only for cpu for us for good on the
procedure
so we don't recommend that probably
because they are more focused on gpu and
friends
and there's two types of study
compensation the first one is cost
training quantization
this is the type of quantization when
you just take your weight of neural net
and you just change numbers
and the second one also
hispanical approach that's
conversational web training but need to
you need to see the little bit more data
to neural net you can think of it about
how
somehow like
the second you need to make your model
weightless
yeah so
here's the table this quick results we
got
during the two months so
yeah the first column is the graphite
torch implementation for inference for
encoders like that listed here
so this is the
just very bird the silver and two uh
mini language models that is actually
have less parameters than
this burton berg
so yeah
so the first column is verified torch
the second one is the built in by torch
quantization so you can actually
quantize the model like inside your
python code
for uh f16 only
and the third column is the tensor item
engine actually the tangent not only the
quantizer model but also made the
cleaning of the neural net and lots of
uh quantities a lot of optimization
inside
and the
last column
but the most interesting one is the
inpaid tensor runtime engine but it's
not out of the box it's manual and
handcrafted
yeah
so the most interesting result is in the
right
bottom
cell
yeah the
sorry
so this what are what these numbers
represent here yeah that's the sequences
per second okay yeah the max lens of
sequences for this
experiment is uh
uh
256
i think yeah and the batch size was uh
varied from
228 to
512
so yeah
how we actually measure our quality of
our models
we use the semantic special similarity
that's the part of blue benchmark and
that's the simple idea you have
two sentences you encode them after that
you just come the assigned distance or
similarity
and you also have
the ground truth and the human markup
this human just
decide whether these two sentences are
similar and
make the score from one to five this is
0.2 step so after that you just measure
the rank correlation between them
and every single result from the
previous table
that run the
quantization from for instance uh where
i torch to tensor run time
into eight didn't lose this uh matrix
even for one percent
so yeah there is no drop no significant
drop you actually can control it but
we'll speak about it later
uh so yeah so how how can you reproduce
the results you can take uh
almost any high phase model because if
your model have some custom layers
there's
there's no way to do that in uh without
the
handwritten uh
interface for tenderloin
so yeah after that you can
make the serialization to when it's
graph
it actually looks like
that that is the only star
uh yeah
so uh after that you can pass your graph
to any runtime you want uh
so yeah
you can do that on it sometime when it's
also
it's internal runtime but more for cpu
actually it's better to actually see
your influence on coming from them
or you can choose the
tensor and time to
better performance to hire too high
performance
you actually can see here
the max lens determined and the batch
size but actually here is the example
that you actually can leave it to your
own track to determine what is the best
the what is better to
build better better nice lens and brush
size for the model to improve faster
yeah after that you need to set up your
executor and profiler
and streams also yeah for data
and just to
make the difference it's
actually almost out of the box
but that's results only for
floor 16 distance right time if you want
integrate around time you need to
customize uh
lots of code you need
actually control that your drop of
accuracy is not significant and sounds
close so yeah here also the link uh with
the
pre-built docker containers with three
conservers with accelerated uh gpu
inference setup with lots of flavors
like two glass and stuff like that
so yeah well that's not quantization for
sure so the pruning permeated the
process when you just trying to remove
redundant operation inside the neural
nets
you can
remove some redundant neural and
connections that makes your nets like
less computation so
yeah so what else uh the one more option
is the distillation
uh this session the process when you try
to
uh
initialize the process this teacher
model that is bigger much more parameter
than the student model and you try to
reproduce the result your teaching model
can get
so
your loss is the difference between the
predictions and you back problem to the
student model so you try to train this
user model by the mistakes competition
model
yeah the actually the distillation is
not the only one option to make your
models smaller you also can transfer
some knowledge for instance
you can make your student model
multilingual or maybe you can make it
like a sentence based not only
word-based
in folder
so yeah what else uh there's lots of
options actually uh the interesting is
uh you can take some other weapons not
only the buy search you can try
different compilers that build
high and built for machine learning
you can try some
uh libraries from indian descendants
make say custom neural nets
and layers for faster interns
so yeah
but anyway to get
the high performance like uh
yeah 100k sequences per second you need
to customize everything and work a lot
so yeah but what you can start with you
can start with vanilla pie torch uh it's
easy and overload any high in phase
model and just make the inference uh you
can enable that market
mix precision that's
built in by torch as i already said
uh you can serialize your model to onyx
graph and after that use the for
instance onyx runtime for
faster inference in cpu or you can try
to put your own graph to a
tensor implant to accelerate the gpu
entrance
hello
so guys actually we have one
of one of the guy in the audience as a
special guest shot is welcome to join me
to discuss a little bit more about the
theory of quantization and so of course
um imagine if the guys want i will say
more examples of how this is achieved
and what are the means behind
all of the cool keywords that oma has
just mentioned
okay
so
just to elaborate a little more on what
every point here means so that's
quantization
so
who has a clue of why quantization
actually
works so what's the benefit of this
thing
we have less bits
i mean we don't need that
right
yeah but
if we don't need that precision what is
that allows us to have higher
performance but by reducing the number
of deaths like uh
uh when talking about competition we may
even uh
mean that we are using integers right
because and
integer operations are much much faster
exactly
and the same thing
uh applies to much shorter floating
point
uh
operations exactly so
uh whenever you don't do it
if
yes
so when we go down from floating point
arithmetic to integer arithmetic we get
the benefit of being able to represent
some of the arithmetical operations with
less
uh transistors
so
if you take modern gpus like the a100s
which are considered the state of the
art for ai training
what we generally have is a huge part of
the dye that is responsible for
floating math arithmetic and then we
only have a few lures our mythological
units so in the past the logic like the
idea behind all of this hardware
diversion was that cpus are good in
integer arithmetic and on the gpus like
within floating point math so in the
past would it be normal not to have any
integer arithmetic on the gpu at all and
almost no floating point arithmetic on
the cpu side now there's kind of a
convergence back towards like similar
kind of homogeneous architectures
and we start getting integer cores let's
say integer processing units on the gpus
as well but even if we take let's say
the a100 we open up the website and
unfortunately we don't have the
technical means to show this on the
bigger screen we would see that they may
suggest something like 300 operations
per second for matrix multiplications
including point 16 arithmetic but also
the kind of the same for u16 so which is
unsigned integers 16 bits
uh so we kind of get the same
performance number but one of the big
benefits here is that to get to this
performance we needed less space on the
die less space it means less transistors
less transistors less cooling and we can
actually feed more on the same chip so
if you look a little wider towards how
machine learning is evolving these days
and not just the inference part but the
training as well we're getting towards
the age where we can have more brands of
hardware including companies like
ravcore or cerebros and stuff like that
who would prioritize or can prioritize
just integer arithmetic in case there
are software's that it's ready to cut to
kind of
uh transition and quantize the entire
neural network so this is kind of the
topic that we wanted to discuss further
with you later on the next meetups
potentially maybe in office like how
quantization can be done during training
as well so how can you do quantization
aware training the part that volvo
mentioned here like the last point
then the dynamic quantization part here
is
a bit over misleading so dynamicization
is like a very broad uh description
every brand just like does it in a
different way if you're like even in
practice even with gpus even though it
says cpu only you can have floating
points cells floating point
cells and matrices and then during the
computation the
cost will take place almost implicitly
down casting the flow 32 number down to
16 and then doing the multiplication on
the tensor cores with a tf 32 precision
with like the tensor closest credit here
then in terms of specification and
pruning again those parts those two
things also exist both during training
and outside of the training and then the
distillation part as also you've
mentioned is kind of one of those things
when
um
you can have
again a trainer for knowledge
distillation but also weight
distillation and then there's the last
part which kind of missed but it's one
of those parts that you may use even
more often so if you take a an engine
like pie torch pie torch comes with
a bunch of bells and whistles you can
configure the way you want
uh including there's like a torch script
version which is essentially an embedded
jit compiler for your pipeline
it will not work with every single model
it will not work with every single model
even from hydrogen phase portal but
sometimes it does
and
it's not the only brand so
there are a lot of companies who exist
solely
for often for compiler level
optimizations for machine learning
pipelines
what what do they do aside from all the
first like three points we mentioned
they actually also understand how the
hardware is built so that the software
stack doesn't have to suffer from it so
one of the big problems that our company
also often tries to solve is let's say
memory bounds so
logic and compute is very cheap compared
to memory accesses but modern neural
networks are too big to fit into the
sram of the chip so you have to fetch it
from the video memory from gtr 6 or hdm2
whatever
runs your gpu
so the problem there is that even if you
take the cpu numbers the memory access
can be 300 times more expensive than the
computation let's say the arithmetic of
adding the numbers
so if the bottleneck is so severe and if
you have an onyx graph uh like this
describing that we do one terminal and
then only the other it means that first
we have
i could have kernel we could program
let's say that does an element-wise
operation on every part of the matrix
that you fit uh fed in
but then the kernel ends the data is
offloaded back into main memory and then
the second kernel proceeds doing another
element-wise operation on the same data
so one of the simple tricks that
compilers can do but not every software
package can do without going
down to that level is kernel fusion so
if you are doing element wise operations
and multiple layers in a row it makes a
lot of sense to actually load the data
into the gpu registers on every single
core just once do all the operations you
need and then also to memory once
uh it's kind of uh easy to do on the cpu
side it's much harder with
custom accelerators especially let's say
ai hardware
and then there is a bit about this
numbers that i can briefly mention
before returning the mic back to you
so
uh experiments are hard to maintain
uh especially data science experiments
written in python so the numbers that
are valid here may not be valid tomorrow
after tomorrow some packages might not
even build
um especially the ones that require
custom configuration so the numbers that
you see on the right uh in the right
column the trt i8 it's kind of similar
to the
state-of-the-art numbers claimed on
nvidia's website for that benchmark so
whenever they release a new lineup of
gpus they pick two reference cards uh in
the general generation it's a 100 and
840 if i'm not mistaken or 810 something
small
and they kind of describe what kind of
performance you can squeeze it you go
all the way
so
uh
we succeeded in replicating those
numbers uh we are 100 certain that is
like not the absolute end you can do a
lot a lot more research it's just that
modern packages do not do that so we
also did
some we'll start with let's say
tensorflow and with tensorflow what you
get is
uh
generally performance that without
custom configurations in pytorch is
similar sometimes the deployment is
easier and sometimes there's there will
say plus or minus twenty percent of
variance with pytorch at least from our
uh experience and especially the textual
models assuming that transformers
library is built mainly on titan engine
uh it's somewhat easier to configure
foster back-end and even on our
corporate portal we sometimes describe
the small bells and whistles people can
configure in high-end packages even in
python so when you take numpy you can
choose which blast library to run
underneath somewhere here you can enable
some of the custom optimizations and
fighters that are not enabled by default
and even if you are not going to
downcast your float32s and to close 16
you can enable implicit procedures like
that that will happen behind the scenes
in the engine itself and in that case so
the number that is described here for
pytorch for f16
uh for mini alarm 6 i think you can get
up to let's say eight or nine thousand
operations per second
with tensorflow we didn't get that far
uh and uh
maybe uh
that's the main points that i wanted to
cover just
as a final notice and then if you are
certain that you are using only the most
mainstream architecture such as you are
not going to use some form of a mini
alarm or some specific sentence
transformer uh you are doing text you
only use bird base on case
probably the most downloaded
pre-trained image on the hiding face
portal in that case
nvidia's and tencent libraries might
work out of the box
not always but that's generally the case
okay thank you very much